hi my name is Imran Baba I am the
president for asia-pacific region of
PepsiCo so today I would like to refer
to the question about Asian woman is the
way forward and what will be the role of
woman in the future in East Asia what
kind of a role do they play how can we
develop their skills going forward first
of all I want to say that women
constitute a big majority of shoppers
for most products in our case it's about
70% of our shoppers woman so we have to
have them in business in decision-making
points positions the second one is we
need the diversity of ideas in our
business we need also the diversity of
styles in our business so in terms of
ideas of course ideas will drive
innovation and innovation will bring
sustainable growth so that's what we are
looking for and in terms of different
styles women can bring to the workplace
the feminine leadership characteristics
which will go very well together with
the masculine leadership characteristics
and at the end of today we will have
more collaboration teamwork sharing
success as a team and empathy and also
concerned for the social matters and in
haste in East Asia what we are seeing
today there is a big potential in some
of our markets Thailand Vietnam women do
work and create a lot of wealth but in
markets like if you go to the north of
course the numbers go down in Japan and
Korea so I think it's corporations we
should be able to attract more women and
retain more women and also develop more
woman and as PepsiCo we are doing all
these things in our own hemisphere and
we try to share it with also external
partners and make it even a bigger
agenda woman will be part of the future
economy